alonzo l Hamby is distinguished
professor of history emeritus at Ohio
University a member of the American
Historical Association since 1962
dr. Hamby earned his BA from Southeast
Missouri State University his MA from
Columbia University and his PhD from the
University of Missouri he is a recipient
of two National Endowment for the
Humanities fellowships a harry s truman
library institute senior fellowship a
Woodrow Wilson international center for
scholars fellowship and the Ohio Academy
of History Distinguished Service Award
he is the author of several books
including the Imperial years the United
States since 1939 man of Destiny FDR in
the making of the American century
liberalism and its challengers FDR to
Reagan and man of the people a life of
harry s truman please join me in
welcoming Alonzo L Hamby
well it's a great pleasure to be here I
am going to try to take you through a
little ride on the history of the
Democratic Party it may be a fast ride
and may leave you with some questions
which I'll be happy to try to answer
when I get through political parties as
Americans understand that term are
relatively recent developments they were
not to be found in the ancient or early
modern worlds they began to emerge only
toward the end of the 18th century as
Whigs and Tories in England Whigs and
Democrats in the United States
at first they were regarded with
suspicion as vehicles for individual
ambition the authors of the Federalist
Papers didn't anticipate them for
example they soon became essential
vehicles of self-rule because they
provided the means of establishing a
popular mandate and translating it into
action the Democratic Party of the
United States is the oldest such vehicle
in the world it was originally founded
to advance the career and ideals of
Thomas Jefferson and Jefferson's
immediate successors but it also has
demonstrated throughout its history
multiple practical and ideological
adjustments to changing times and
political imperative
let's begin with Jefferson and the
values for which he stood in 1776 as the
author of the Declaration of
Independence Jefferson laid out these
values as eloquently as they have ever
been spoken we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that to secure
these rights governments are instituted
among men deriving their just powers
from the consent of the governed that
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends it is the
right of the people to alter or abolish
it and to institute new government
well eloquent indeed well written in the
Declaration of Independence indeed but
what about Negro slavery and what
especially about Sally Hemings the
mixed-race slave widely known then and
generally accepted today to have been
Jefferson's mistress after the death of
his wife Sally Hemings was probably the
offspring of Jefferson's father-in-law
she had been the personal servant of
Jefferson's wife
she seems to have been accomplished and
attractive very possibly having traveled
to France with Jefferson and Jefferson's
wife fluent in French after two decades
of controversy and denial
it appears finally to have become widely
accepted that the Jefferson Hemings
relationship existed I mention it
because it exemplifies in microcosm a
dilemma that plagued the early history
of the Democratic Party
how did Democrats collectively reconcile
the Jeffersonian values of liberal
democracy with the institution the
Jefferson himself practiced of human
slavery for around three-quarters of a
century in the South Democrats did so by
noisily proclaiming white supremacy
after the Civil War and reconstruction
they enforced it in what became the
solidly democratic South with a widely
accepted institution of lynching that
persisted well into the 20th century and
perhaps a bit more mildly with the
institution of segregation which is the
great historian C Vann Woodward showed
us long ago really became an institution
only after the Civil War and
reconstruction
to put it bluntly the Democratic Party
primarily in the south but with the
acquiescence of its northern wing
proceeded from the assumption that
democracy existed for white men only by
and large white northerners quietly
accepted this development Woodrow Wilson
the great progressive Democrat of the
early 20th century had also been born in
Staunton Virginia and spent his early
years farther in the deep south Wilson
as president rebuffed a delegation of
black activists who obtained a meeting
with him southerners and Wilson's
cabinet instituted segregation in their
departments departments that had under
Republican rule in the late 19th and
early 20th century been desegregated
increasingly however smaller numbers of
Republicans dissented from what had
become a national consensus so much now
then for races for issues of racial
equality and the patient's they inspired
will return to them what are their
continuities do we find in the 19th
century Democratic Party may have been
the party of the slavery but it also was
the party of the people the development
widely exemplified early on in the 19th
century by the presidency of Andrew
Jackson a popular general who made
himself a national hero by routing the
British invasion force at New Orleans in
the final battle of
war of 1812 a leader who had risen from
poverty and a slave owner himself
Jackson capitalized on his humble
beginnings and Exploited it as an asset
his identity as a self-made man Jackson
also exemplified the quandary of a party
that would be torn between largely
incompatible faiths in states rights and
strong executive leadership Andrew
Jackson was nothing if not a strong
president he faced down South Carolina's
attempts to nullify the so called tariff
of abominations by threatening to lead
an armed force into the state himself
and quite possibly hang its leaders if
it was necessary to compel enforcement
Andrew Jackson was not a subtle man he
also instituted what would become a
rather standard long-standing democratic
policy of hostility toward financial
elites he was intensely skeptical of the
nationally chartered bank of the United
States a counterpart of the Bank of
England which might roughly be
considered a 19th century forerunner to
today's Federal Reserve System he
refused to bank to back renewal of the
bank's Charter which expired in 1836 or
to replace it with some other banking
regulatory system the result was
financial chaos and a sharp recession
that would be inherited by his
successor martin van buren interestingly
enough
Jackson's reputation in the popular
imagination was hardly scathed van
Buuren took the rap for the recession
Van Buren's successors John Tyler the
Democrat who became a nominal Whig as
William Henry Harrison's vice
presidential candidate Harrison of
course lived only a month in office
Tyler and James K Polk elected as a
Democrat to succeed him made the party
The Tribune of continental expansion it
was they who added between them added
Texas the American Southwest and the
Oregon Territory below the 39th parallel
to the Union impressive in themselves
these accomplishments nonetheless
intensified a growing controversy over
the extension of slavery that
underscored an ominous development in
the 1850s as the Whig Party
disintegrated the Democratic Party
struggling to preserve its identity as a
nation's only truly National Party
increasingly became the party of slavery
the party looking for some sort of a
formula that would satisfy both the
slave south and a northern population
that was increasingly trending toward
abolition the result probably the
irrepressible inevitable result the
Civil War underscored that image
so did the era of reconstruction when
Lincoln's successor his vice president
Union Democrat Andrew Johnson advocated
a mild policy toward the south was
impeached and escaped ejection from
office by only one vote what followed as
reconstruction was more or less settled
by caving in to southern resistance and
allowing the southern states to adopt US
policy of segregation and black
subjugation just a step removed from
slavery what followed the so-called
Gilded Age was an era of Republican
dominance marked by impressive economic
expansion as a result between 1865 and
1913 only one Democrat occupied the
White House Grover Cleveland for two
non-consecutive terms you know you can
take your pick Grover Cleveland was
either the 22nd and the 24th President
of the United States or you can just
call him a 22nd and be done with it in
truth the policy differences between
Cleveland and his Republican opponents
were minimal the Republican Party
quickly put reconstruction behind it and
Cleveland was not about to offend the
large southern Democratic bloc in
Congress and usually a minority in
Congress the Democrats were most often
publicly publicly represented by
unreconstructed southerners who defended
the harsh repression of negro
citizens and the institution of racial
segregation all this began to change in
the late 19th and early 20th centuries
with the age of reform that has become
known as the populist Progressive Era
populism was primarily a revolt of hard
pressed farmers primarily wheat farmers
in the Midwest and cotton farmers in the
south
both caught in the throes of an
unfavorable world market that was
emerging in the late 19th century the
first Democratic populist leader was of
course William Jennings Bryan a
Nebraskan of formidable oratorical
powers and in his early years which he
secured his first Democratic nomination
for president 1896 Bryan was concerned
primarily with the grievances of these
debt burdened farmers both north and
south
Bryan of of course coming from Nebraska
was particularly answerable to wheat
farmers addressing the federal standard
that US currency was redeemable in gold
and advocating an inflationary policy
Bryan rejected what he called the
crucifixion of mankind on a cross of
gold and advocated free coinage of
silver in effect policy that would allow
all the silver mined in the United
States
to be sold to the US Mint and claimed
this would have a significant
inflationary impact most Americans
understood it and refused to buy it
Brian
wind up running for president three
times losing each time he's remembered
today
not altogether fairly but not altogether
unfairly either as the eloquent but
simple-minded leader of a rural
constituency out of touch with an
increasingly urban and industrial nation
he would go on of course to undertake in
his later years of crusade against the
teaching of evolution and the public
schools the populist movement of course
is succeeded by brother Morgan complex
reform movement that historians refer to
as the progressive movement of the early
20th century a reaction against the
political power of large corporations in
an effort to deal with pressing urban
problems created by mass immigration and
venal political bosses America's first
progressive president would be the
Republican Theodore Roosevelt followed
by the hand-picked but rather maladroit
William Howard Taft Taft's mishandling
of tariff issues and his innate
conservatism limited him to one term it
also brought Theodore Roosevelt's back
into electoral politics as a candidate
of the 1912 Progressive Party splitting
what was normally a Republican vote
between them
Taft and Roosevelt paved the way for the
election of the democratic progressive
Woodrow Wilson and it's Wilson the
Democrat not Teddy Roosevelt who was the
great reformed president of the early
twentieth century his list of
accomplishments included the
establishment of the Federal Reserve
System the stimulation of foreign trade
through a sharp lowering of the
protective tariffs antitrust legislation
a graduated income tax an eight-hour
workday for railway workers it was
Wilson who appointed the great liberal
legal thinker Louis Brandeis to the
Supreme Court on domestic issues he
established himself as the most
important president of the early
twentieth century
Wilson's big failure came in his
handling of World War one not in his
decision to intervene in 1917 on the
side of the beleaguered allies Great
Britain and France this was morally and
strategically correct Imperial Germany
was a clear threat to American interests
and to world stability Britain and
France were not Wilson understood all
this his real failure came with the
post-war settlement and his refusal to
amend in any way his proposed League of
Nations Republicans Theodore Roosevelt
included thought that the league as
Wilson
established it had it written into the
Treaty of Versailles they thought the
league just put too much in the way of
limitations on American freedom of
action in the world perhaps it did
Wilson's stubbornness to compromise
transformed a great success into failure
the crippling stroke left him disabled
for the final year and a half of his
presidency he left office in 1921 a
bitter man who had paved the way for 12
years of Republican supremacy it would
be left after Harding Coolidge and
Hoover in the beginning of the Great
Depression for Franklin D Roosevelt to
create a lasting political world in
which the Democrats were the normal
majority party Roosevelt created a
vastly larger federal government with a
wide mission of social activism at home
and world leadership abroad agricultural
price supports corporate regulation
protection for labor unions large relief
in Public Works programs for the
unemployed to this we should say also
Roosevelt added a talent for the radio
the main means of mass communication
during his presidency unlike any
president before him and perhaps unlike
any president even who succeeded him
by and large Roosevelt's Democratic
successors over the past three quarters
of a century have affirmed the mission
that he outlined even as they may have
tweaked it now and again Roosevelt also
became the leader of the world's
struggle but against fascism in World
War two he provided the inspiration for
Lyndon Johnson's Great Society programs
and LBJ's advocacy of civil rights
Lyndon Johnson we should add first came
to Washington as a congressman from
Texas during the Roosevelt presidency
was a devoted acolyte of Roosevelt and
one of his favorite young congressman no
president not even Ronald Reagan himself
by the way an enthusiastic Roosevelt
supporter in his younger days has
attempted to roll back the achievements
of the New Deal and no president not
even Jimmy Carter has abandoned the
position of free world leadership that
Franklin Roosevelt established for the
United States well what's the stop with
Roosevelt oh I think in many ways
established the political world in which
we live in today however much various
successors have tweaked it a bit how
might Thomas Jefferson have felt about
all of this
well the Jefferson Memorial was largely
a Franklin D Roosevelt project dedicated
during his presidency and really
established with his story
support Roosevelt seems to have assumed
that his New Deal and his promotion of
the goals of a liberal world order were
consistent with those of Jefferson I'm
not at all sure Jefferson would have
thought so but I am certain that the
implementation of his values and policy
required adaptation to the world of the
20th century well further today's
Democratic Party for now I narrate the
party of Hillary Clinton and Tim Kaine I
think it's safe to say a party that
Roosevelt and most of his Democratic
successors until we get to the very
recent past would have been quite
surprised about where is the future of
the Democratic Party what is it well I
think the smartest thing for a historian
to do on this issue is simply to say the
future lies before us and quit talking
and needless to say I'll be happy to
take any questions may even be able to
provide answers to some of them
you mentioned that FDR was very
instrumental in creating the Jefferson
Memorial but this in the ceiling of that
is inscribed that he fought against
every tyranny over the mind of man that
seemed like FDR was the beginning of the
tyranny over the mind of man you comment
on why he why that inscription was put
in there under his aegis well I'm going
to defend Roosevelt on that one
anyway to the to the extent that he was
able to exercise any tyranny over the
minds of men it was the radio speeches
not not through a Gestapo
thank you very much for speaking with us
today my questions regarding what seems
to be a switch in the policies from the
1800's to the 1900s after FDR what
really caused Adamic Democratic Party to
switch its policies from what seemed to
be a more conservative tone it's what
you now see is more progressive more
open to the black community as opposed
to segregating it well seems that back
then the Democratic Party was again anti
black Crow segregation pro-slavery and
now that all seems to have switched what
would you say it would be done well the
the big switch of course does come in
the 1930s it needless to say does not
extend to the southern democrats it is
largely pulled off by FDR with a big
role being played by his wife Eleanor I
think we can say that FDR himself who
was sort of an adopted southerner by the
way you know there's this very
interesting chapter in his life after
he's stricken with polio in 1921 where
he winds up spending a lot of time in
Georgia trying to recuperate from polio
at Warm Springs hoping vainly as it
turned out that he could regain the use
of his legs by exercising there it's
never successful at that but he is
successful in making himself an adopted
Georgian and by extent an adopted
southerner
his wife Eleanor during most of this
period in the 20s is not down there with
him but back in New York
becoming a rather important social
reformer in New York democratic politics
herself and she's she's quite taken by
the plight of the black population even
in the north and is very friendly to
civil rights there's there's no civil
rights legislation as such as bills
passed by Congress under FDR because
southern senators will filibuster it but
there are executive actions
notably the Fair Employment Practices
committee of World War two but the the
president who really nails his program
to the civil rights movement is
intriguingly harry s truman a native of
missouri which had been as all of us who
have read mark twain know a slave state
before the Civil War and which
particularly certain of its areas was
was very southern
Truman's own rationale was complex fair
amount of it was political it is both as
a political candidate in in Missouri
where he had served successively as
the chief executive officer of Jackson
County Missouri which is basically
Kansas City and it's rural environs and
then later on as a senator from Missouri
he had needed that black vote and he was
actually descended from slave owners if
you look at some of the language that
Harry Truman used in private because
after all he had grown up in a fairly
prejudiced environment and carried over
into his speech you wouldn't think it
was acceptable but my own interpretation
of Truman is that he came to believe
that civil rights legislation was the
right thing to do
and the black citizens might be black
but that they were entitled to all the
rights of citizens but that was Truman
an increasing amount of the black vote
went to Roosevelt because by and large
among other things the federal public
works program that he instituted gave
fair employment opportunities to blacks
and when World War Two came along he's
he went along with the agitation for a
fair employment practices committee that
would try to give blacks a fair shake in
the World War two full employment
workplace so that's sort of it in a
nutshell I hope that speaks to your
question
by what legerdomain did the name
democrat party be changed to the
misnomer of democratic party I I think
it was probably it was probably an
attack levied against a Democrat by
teachers of English I don't know it
frankly just doesn't sound right
linguistically and if if you're saying
that a lot of the practices particularly
in the South weren't democratic small D
democratic sure you're absolutely right
my question is you mentioned how FDR led
the fight against fascism I'm wondering
how fascism what did FDR see in fascism
that clashed against his own values and
his views of socialism well yeah there
are some people who argue and then you
can make this argument to a certain
extent that the early phase of the New
Deal in which its its central agency the
National Recovery administration
attempted to organize the economy in
ways that institutionally bore a
resemblance to avoid that Mussolini had
organized the Italian economy that is
and Mussolini's a case that was organize
the economy into syndicates of
like-minded business that then would be
regulated by the state
well the NRA did the same
thing only it avoided the use of the
word syndicate the the difference is
that in the end the NRA
well it might theoretically be telling
different kinds of business what to do
might be issuing myriad regulations for
them might have the theoretical power of
enforcement simply conduct that way in a
democratic environment and it sort of
fell apart of its own weight and was was
basically on the way out when it was
effectively abolished
how do you see the muscular foreign
policy of Roosevelt Truman Kennedy and
Johnson evolving into the Obama policies
well I guess short answer is I'm not
sure I see it evolving at all into the
Obama administration but I think yeah
you're quite right in saying you're
looking at muscular foreign policies
here I think it's it's fair particularly
to say in the case of Roosevelt and
Truman that they they moved in
unprecedented ways to protect the
national interest and by and large you
know they were largely right I think if
if Franklin Roosevelt made any serious
foreign policy mistake it certainly was
in his belief that he could establish a
lasting mutual helpful mutually helpful
relationship with Joseph Stalin of
course he didn't live to see how that
probably would have worked out and we
don't know how he would have reacted but
how did we get from there to Barack
Obama
I think Obama's probably best understood
is the coming from the latest generation
and the wave of the waves actually of
reactions against the Vietnam War
and the well let's call it what it is
the creeping isolationist to belief that
the United States has very few vital
interests abroad you know I I suppose
if the Soviet Union tried to invade West
Germany we would react if the Soviet
Union decides to occupy Latvia I'm not
sure what we'd do today and I think it's
a dangerous situation
I uh thank you for coming to speak to us
you talked about earlier about how FDR
issued executive orders concerning the
equal protection under law for labor do
you and the Democratic Party believe
that is better for one man to
unilaterally force a moral policy such
as that equal job opportunity protection
then then it is better for the people to
suffer an injustice until the people
themselves comes to come to the
conclusion that that policy that they
had currently is it moral than you need
that they need to change it
well there is no way a fair employment
Protection Agency was going to be was
going to get through Congress at the
beginning of World War two so we have to
we have to face that the the southern
block and the Roosevelt and Truman
Congress's was resolutely dead-end
segregationist and would never have
stood for it there was the problem
Roosevelt faced of facilitating war
production
there was an emerging more militant
civil rights movement would not buy the
not so much for the n-double-a-cp
but by the hint of the railway porters
Union a philip Randolph Randolph was
threatening if something wasn't done and
get this this would seem pretty tame to
us today but seemed much less tame and
the atmosphere of the time a mass march
on Washington and Roosevelt had decided
I think
that the march on Washington could be as
many people thought maybe a Messick
thing might become violent and you know
we can look at that today and say well
there have been a lot of marches on
Washington since then they've managed to
stay under control that was not so
obvious in those days so he issued this
order for fair employment practices
committee now we should be clear that
the powers of the FPPC were pretty
limited if an employer really wanted to
defy them that employer could and he
could get away with it but it did an
operation have have sort of a moral
force in wartime and during the war
itself the big big constantly nagging
civil rights issue was whether it would
be or could be continued after the war I
think everyone realized that it couldn't
go on indefinitely as a wartime agency
established by executive Fiat well it
couldn't be gotten through with Congress
congressional authorization either so
that was basically it there was some
some protests about the rapid phasing
out of the FPPC and i-i-i have no
particular considered opinion on whether
harry truman did it too rapidly or not
Truman Truman counted the votes in
Congress he knew they weren't there
as a former senator himself he respected
congressional prerogative so he let it
expire and would it would remain you
know an often on civil rights issue
until we finally have the legislation of
the sixties would you say that if you
look at the bureaucracy of our
government today that the problems that
were encountered with the NRA have been
solved by the bureaucracy today good
should they be solved by the bureaucracy
today well haven't paid in solve by this
I you know I I think they probably be
made worse the the problem with the the
problem with the NRA was conceptual you
know was whether whether any agency
could provide fair and widely accepted
regulation over every significant
segment of the economy over the long run
and may have had some utility as an
emergency agency who gave a little bit
of a jolt to the economy but yeah it's
hard to see how we could have something
like the the NRA existing today over the
long run and as I've suggested it may
not have been an altogether unqualified
setback for Roosevelt that it was given
a decent execution and burial by the
Supreme Court in 1935 because they're
probably just would have been mounting
dissatisfaction with it and it would
have had to wither away in one way or
another
this way we have a question down here in
front that we'll get to in a minute yes
sir thank you very much for speaking in
front of us today um my question is
response to the various factions of the
Democratic Party that you've outlined to
us today particularly with regard to the
Southern Democrats if you were to look
at the party of Clinton and Kaine today
with its modern tensions how would you
draw the various factional fault lines
in their current coalition how would I
draw factional fault lines in the party
today well it's a good question when
when Franklin Roosevelt and Harry Truman
were president the governor of Virginia
was Harry Byrd an unreconstructed
southerner who was at the head of a
powerful Virginia political machine that
really controlled the state it was
widely accepted in Virginia Harry Berg
was a reactionary the Virginia of today
is not the Virginia of those days and
Tim came today as a governor that never
would have been governor and in those
days I think one of the things that's
happened in Virginia is Washington DC
gets bigger and bigger there is a larger
and larger population that lives in
Northern Virginia and commutes into DC
or maybe doesn't even commute maybe
works and one sort or another of
government related employment in
suburban DC Virginia
so the Virginia of today and its
politics is much different
the small government conservatism of
Harry bird was popular in Harry Birds
day Harry Truman once remarked and he
was he was thinking not just a very bird
but also of a Senator Robert Byrd of
West Virginia who seemingly served in
the Senate forever
his Truman remark there are too many
birds in the Senate he found them found
them both real problems for a liberal
president but Virginia of today is much
different it's a much more moderate
state it's not the well as Harry Byrd
would have called it not the
Jeffersonian conservative state once was
we have time for one more question thank
you very much for presenting your
information in a way that I could see
patterns and connections I feel better
with patterns and connections and facts
however there's something you mentioned
as an answer to a question that has been
a quandary you mentioned Barack Obama is
tending to be an isolationist however I
look at the history of what he's been
doing his intervention in brexit his
intervention in Israeli politics their
desire his desire to bring more Syrians
over rather than helping them develop a
safe area nearer home
I can't reconcile those patterns with
the term isolationism if you could clear
that up for me I would appreciate it
well okay maybe yeah I mean you're using
a sense in a more inclusive term but I
would use it I think you seem to be
saying that in opposition to immigration
for example
the case of Syrians and as far as that
goes the case of Mexicans is required if
you're an isolationist and I think
clearly Obama and many Democrats look at
this immigration and they see votes
particularly if they're vocally
encouraging it and the Republicans are
vocally opposing it so I you know I
don't think don't think the the term
works very well and that but as far as
you know the we have some very
interesting things going on in the South
China Sea for example we have some very
interesting things going on off off
Latvia when we have an American naval
task force in international waters their
Chinese claims Russian planes buzzing
aircraft carriers having it's impossible
that someday we're going to have a
Russian or a Chinese pilot who maybe
gets a little too overeager and smashes
his plane into one of them and what's
going to happen then and is it possible
to take measures that will discourage
that
so maybe isolationist is not quite the
best term to use with Obama but let's
say he's certainly shying away not only
for military intervention but also
Shanno from sending military aid to the
Ukrainians you know I think probably
none of us would want to send American
troops to you
but providing the Ukrainians with
armament against Russian aggression you
know they are after all an independent
country these days supposedly seems to
me something of a different order you
think clearly there's there's a lot of a
lot of shyness there there's a lot of
shyness about not trying to do too much
about the Iranians who are harassing
American vessels in the Persian Gulf -
and you have to wonder sooner or later
is there going to be some kind of an
incident when a foreign pilot
miscalculates we'll see if Barack Obama
is very lucky maybe not
thank you dr. Hamby thank you